Most rich people, they're obviously they
wear nice suits and they're well
educated, they speak posh. They don't
have a clue what what's going on.
They're, you know, they're no smarter
than obviously some of them are smart,
but they're no smarter than your average
guy. They're very divorced from what's
happening. They're very rich. They live
in these societies which like give them
unbelievable levels of luxury and they
are really obviously rapidly
aggressively destabil destabilizing
those societies to to get a little bit
more. It's so stupid. If the rich were
smart, they would be trying to call a
ceasefire here. They've won. They've got
everything. They're unbelievably rich.
And yet, they're pushing for more.
They're pushing for more in a way that
is going to destroy the societies they
live in. It's the It's the stupidest
thing ever. It's the stupidest thing
ever. So they're not smart.